[Música]
bacterias
pero espera voy a repetirlo porque creo
que me ha ido muy bien
bacterias
y esa sensación cuando tenemos el móvil
se cae y se queda boca abajo
momento tenso del día
50% de probabilidad
en estas dos cosas en común que nos
aterran o al menos a la mayoría de
nosotros
cuando alexander fleming descubrió que
uno de sus cultivos bacterianos había
estado contaminado por hongos lo primero
que pensó
o en tirarlo
pero por suerte para nosotros decidió
examinarlo y darse cuenta de por qué
esas bacterias no podían crecer
alrededor
y así nació el primer antibiótico de la
penicilina
imaginaos la de gente que habrá salvado
este hombre por un error es más la de
gente que habrán salvado los hongos y
las bacterias
la verdad
cuando pensamos en el futuro siempre
pensamos en avances tecnológicos
brutales coches voladores allí
y prótesis mecánicas al ironman
pero es que el futuro es muchísimo más
pequeño de lo que parece de hecho es el
tamaño de 0 0 0 0 0 0
a 1 metros y se llama bacteria
como público entregado que sois voy a
pedir un gran favor es más un esfuerzo
mental y ello mirad la siguiente imagen
una papaya no una bacteria así que como
nos va a estar acompañando durante toda
la presentación y yo no soy muy buen
dibujante vamos a imaginarnos que eso es
así el caso es que quiero que os deis
cuenta de que dentro de esa bacteria de
color negro hay
en desordenado
como en todos los seres vivos pero es
que así como un programa informático
ejecuta una orden tras otra nuestro adn
y el de todos los seres vivos son
instrucciones son características que
nos definen como el color de nuestro
pelo o de nuestros ojos
en 1973 herber boyer y stanley coin
consiguieron por primera vez transferir
dna de un organismo a otro en este caso
una bacteria es decir fijémonos bien que
consiguieron hacer consiguieron
transferir características e
instrucciones de un organismo a otro
desde entonces esta técnica ha
evolucionado exponencialmente y hoy en
día ya existe una disciplina que se
encarga de ello la biología sintética
la biología sintética no es una
disciplina cualquiera
de hecho es una de las más democráticas
que conozco porque se sustenta en que la
información que se genere tiene que ser
de acceso público y gratuito a todo el
mundo promueve la accesibilidad
no hay patentes no hay secretos
dónde está la gracia
pues muy fácil si todo el mundo sabe lo
que yo estoy hacía
cuando tiene el mundo tiene dos opciones
o construye a partir de ello o sí y va a
hacer lo mismo que yo estoy haciendo
a otra cosa mariposa no me interesa
competir contigo
todos los años sobre el 28 de octubre se
celebra en boston una competición
ideologías llamada ayer
y si como os comento es una competición
de biología sintéticas donde cualquiera
que la universidad del mundo puede traer
a su equipo de frikis y presentar su
proyecto durante los tres durante la
semana que dura ese proyecto tiene que
estar hecho durante tres meses la de
este año tenía este aspecto
en 2018 no hace tanto la upv se presentó
con un equipo de 11 integrantes de los
cuales uno de ellos
estoy hablando de mi queridísima printer
ya
printer ya es el fruto de tres meses de
esfuerzo de dedicación y bueno de alguna
que otra mesa volando por el despacho la
verdad
pero sobre todo es el fruto de un equipo
multidisciplinar de 10 estudiantes y que
en nuestro equipo habían muchas mentes
diferentes habían ingenieros biomédicos
también ingenieros industriales habían
ingenieros de automática y electrónica
habían biotecnólogos habían estudiantes
de bellas artes y es que todo esto es
necesario para hacer un proyecto de tal
envergadura
así como somos capaces de crear los
robots que nos obedezca la biología
sintética funciona igual pero trabaja
con la tecnología más perfecta del mundo
la célula y programa su adn para que nos
obedezca
hablemos un poquito de ella ella nació
de una idea que a priori parece
imposible y era la de hacer una
impresora que en vez de imprimir en
folios imprimirá directamente en el adn
de las bacterias
os imaginais a vosotros mismos
manipulando bacterias insertando las las
características que vosotros queráis
dejadme contaros de una manera muy
sencilla y rápida cómo lo hemos hecho
uno de los buenos lo primero de todo es
contaros mejor dicho que sprint erial
printer ya no es un producto es un
proyecto y básicamente lo que es es un
mini laboratorio portátil del tamaño del
peso del microondas uno de los objetivos
que tuvimos al hacer puntería era que
fuese tan fácil de usar como el software
de la impresora que cualquiera de
vosotros podéis tener en el despacho o
en casa por eso lo que hemos hecho es
convertir las piezas de dna el dna en
definitiva en piezas de puzzle que
cualquiera puede unir para enviar un
mensaje a la bacteria pero muchísimo
cuidado porque
la bacteria se puede confundir si no lo
hacemos en orden y es que con cada una
de esas piezas yo le estoy indicando a
una cosa esto indicando que quiero
cuánto quiero
cuando lo quiero
y fin del mensaje
si no nos damos de una manera ordenada
la bacteria no nos va a encender
os doy un ejemplo para que nos pongamos
en contexto quiero bacterias
fluorescentes rosas eso sería el que
pero es que además quiero que esas
bacterias sean bien fluorescentes y que
cuando las mire me quemen un poquito la
retina eso sería el cuanto pero sólo
quiero que sean fluorescentes cuando el
medio sea ácido
eso sé cuándo
esto en printer ya se traduce en 4 clics
de ratón y ella misma ya traduce lo que
yo le he dicho en lenguaje adn
una vez yo sé lo que quiero y le doy a
start toda la magia empieza aquí en
printer ya ella ya sabe lo que yo deseo
y esas verdades de devolver tiene todos
los ingredientes que necesito en esos
contenedores pequeños que veis ahí hay
agua necesaria está en nuestras nuestras
piezas detenía a nuestros puzzles están
también nuestras bacterias y unas
cositas que se llaman enzimas que son
unas proteínas que les encanta [ __ ]
todos tenían que juntarlos lo cual nos
viene de perlas
fijaos que lo que hace printer ya como
habéis visto el gif es que baja una
aguja insufla aire y suelta ese
ingrediente encima de una placa metálica
lo primero de todo que va a soltar va a
ser una gota de agua y luego ya soltar a
todos los demás ingredientes encima de
esa gota de agua y quedarán suspendidos
porque quiero una gota de agua tiene una
gota de agua por dos razones primero
para posibilitar todas las reacciones
biológicas que se van a producir pero
por otro lado también quiero que sea el
vehículo que transporte mis ingredientes
y es que en biología sintética
en ingeniería genética en cualquier
ciencia en definitiva que utiliza el adn
lo corte y lo pegue necesitamos llevar
esos trozos de adn a zonas frías y a
zonas calientes zonas frías y a zonas
calientes así una vez tras otra
como tenemos eso
porque de momento hay que mover el agua
así por la placa
pues utilizamos un fenómeno físico que
se llama electro waiting es que como
vais a ver esa placa metálica está
constituida por pequeñas plaquitas
separadas
y mediante diferencias de voltaje
podemos conseguir mover el agua y
llevarla donde nosotros deseemos
al final de este proceso ya tenemos el
adn unido ahora simplemente hay que
cogerlo y enviarlo por correo a la
bacteria si no se lo damos ella no lo
puede leer para eso básicamente
absorbemos la gota la llevamos con un
tubo que tenemos y utilizamos una
tecnología ya existente que se llama
electro operador
en el ex operador simplemente son dos
placas metálicas entre las cuales
aplicamos 1200 voltios y eso consigue
meter nuestro dna dentro de las
bacterias
ya lo tenemos y hasta adentro ya puede
leerlo ahora como en cualquier operación
simplemente dejar dejarlas descansar y
que ellas hagan lo suyo
os dais cuenta ahora de por qué
cualquiera puede hacer lo que nosotros
hacemos un laboratorio está todo
automatizado el mundo puede hacer lo que
nosotros hacemos lo único que tiene que
saber es dar cuatro clics
yo lo pienso y digo si pusimos la
ciencia de la computación al servicio de
la ciudadanía y eso supuso ya una
revolución que revolución supondrá
llevar la ciencia del laboratorio a la
misma ciudadanía no será fácil
ninguno de vosotros hace 60 años se
imaginaba con unas water y con un
portátil con una tablet con smart watch
y mucho menos yo menos no estaba ahí
pero es que hacer los objetos accesibles
no se empodera nos da poder si ahora a
mí me da una fibrilación ventricular y
acá me quedo aquí muerto ya estáis
tardando alguien levantaron iros a por
el desfibrilador automático que hay ahí
fuera
imaginaos la accesibilidad si no se
empodera quién nos permite salvar vidas'
printer ya simplemente es un ejemplo más
de que cualquier cosa por imposible que
sea se puede hacer accesible
los invito a hacer un ejercicio a
cerraron los ojos en vuestra casa
pensar en el futuro y decir cuántas
cosas que hay a mi alrededor salen de la
idea de accesibilidad y me están
haciendo la vida muchísimo más fácil
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]